Hello, yeah, I was looking for Pete. Yeah, this Pete Pete what's up dude?
This is jubble from Brook and jubble in the morning. I'm moving 92.5. How are you?
Um, good. Why are you calling?
Uh, I want to talk to you about a mutual friend that you and I have.
Okay, it's a girl named Hannah
Why are you calling me about Hannah?
Well, I know that you went on a date with Hannah and you guys hooked up and the next morning you made her breakfast and everything
seemed cool and and haven't called her so I was calling kind of on Hannah's behalf to ask
why haven't we got back to work?
It's just on an error right now. It's just on the radio right now. Yeah, it is.
Okay, I gotta go. Sorry. No, no, no, no, hang on. Hang on.
Pete, Pete, one second, dude. Please don't hang up.
Paul again.
Dude, Hannah, what did you do?
There's not one to talk about Hannah.
See, we're gonna back.
This is inappropriate, man.
Look, don't hang up. Don't hang up.
No, no, it's bull.
You shouldn't be asking me about my private life here. It's bull.
Okay.
I mean, off the air.
Hang on a second, Pete.
What is this?
Okay. Uh, producer boy just had to be a piece of paper.
Let's true.
Yeah.
Really?
Yes.
Um, apparently Pete, our producer went to your Facebook and it says, you are engaged.
What?
You're joking.
Is this for real?
Oh, my.
Pete, are you engaged, dude?
You hung up.
I heard it, cause I'm thinking you hung up.
Are you joking?
Wow.
That was weird.
All right, we're gonna stop for a second.
I'm trying to sort this out.
I think we need to figure out if this is really true or not.
Okay. So we got an update.
A few minutes ago during the second day of update,
we were calling Pete to find out why he wasn't calling Hannah Beck.
He hung up on us when we first got him on the phone.
So producer boy went to his Facebook page to try to get it like another contact form,
a phone number or something and found out through Pete's Facebook that he was actually engaged.
And apparently producer boy then message to his fiance
and he's telling me that she's on the phone right now.
Is she really on the phone?
Yeah.
She's on one, too.
Is this Jessica?
Yeah.
Do you have a fiance named Pete?
Do you want to have a fiance named Pete?
Yeah.
I don't want to do it.
This is doable from Rick and Jubilee in the morning.
I'm moving 92.5.
Can you describe Pete for me?
He's my fiance.
We've been together for a while.
We're getting married in the summer.
He's okay.
It's really great.
Um, just like why are you asking me those?
This is how long you've been together.
While we've been engaged for about a year or a little over a year.
I'm here.
Hang on Hannah.
Let's make sure this is the right dude.
All right.
Who is this?
This is Brook and Jubilee in the morning.
I'm moving 92.5.
Hannah's on the phone with us.
Hannah emailed us about a guy that she went out with and hooked up with.
Who wouldn't call her back after they, you know, had a night of fun.
That guy is your fiance.
Is this a joke?
No.
Are you kidding me?
That's not possible.
Um, is there any way you've been out of town over the weekends?
Yeah.
When did this happen, Hannah?
On Friday night.
Okay.
Were you with Pete on Friday night?
No.
And he, oh my god.
I know, honey.
And he didn't answer my phone calls or my text on Friday.
And are you, are you got, is this, it's not real?
Jessica, so you, where did Pete tell you he was on Friday night?
He said he had to work late.
Okay.
And he didn't answer any of my text or anything.
And, oh my god, are you kidding me?
Hannah, tell Jessica about what you did Friday night.
I'm really sorry.
I honestly had no idea if this time was engaged.
I thought he was just a great guy and we went on a date.
We went back, you went on a date.
Like a pre-arranged date.
What, you, I'm trying very hard to give him the benefit of the doubt and not freak out right now.
What's Pete's last name?
Jessica, what's Pete's last name?
We'll beat it up.
Hannah, what's the guy's last name that you went out with?
I'm a, oh.
Are you kidding me?
Have you guys had any problems with cheating before in your, no?
And I'm aware of?
Hannah, how did you, how did you meet Pete again?
No, mutual acquaintance.
mutual acquaintance.
Who?
Disguh, Charles.
Jessica is Charles a friend of Pete's that, you know?
Yeah, he's a friend of Pete's.
He's a friend of Pete's that I don't get along with.
Unbelievable.
This is, we tried to cut.
Go out on a date.
Are you saying you were at a party?
Are you, I don't understand what you're saying to me.
Jessica, I would tell you to not get mad at Hannah because it sounds like Hannah legitimately
didn't know that he had a fiance.
So it's, I'm sorry.
I don't know who I'm mad at right now.
I'm just in shock, okay?
Cut me some f*** black hair because if you were in my house Hannah,
PS, you can be as mad as my house.
Wait, Jessica, you live there?
Wait, but you have to, I don't, no pictures of any gold in that house.
Oh my god.
Are you okay, honey?
No, I'm not okay.
I'm not okay, I'm in the hands, I'm not okay at all.
Oh, that makes my heart hurt.
I feel so.
We tried to get Pete on the phone.
Jessica to talk about why he wasn't calling Hannah back and he got angry and hung up on us
obviously because he has a fiance.
I'm sorry you had to hear about it this way.
I am too.
Hey, Jessica, we're gonna give you just a second to compose yourself, okay?
And then we're gonna talk to you a little more, right?
Okay, okay, I'm gonna put it all for one second.
Okay.
All right.
All right, this is the third segment of the second date update today because obviously
things got a little serious.
Hannah went out with a guy named Peter.
They hooked up.
We tried to get him on the phone, he got mad and hung up on us and then we found out that he actually had a fiance.
Jessica, how are you doing?
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm, have you slept during engagement ring down the toilet yet?
Not yet.
Have you suspected him cheating before anything else?
I've had my moments of worrying about that a little bit but I've always told myself to
take the high road and not be accusatory.
Yeah, I would trust the commitment that we've made to each of you should be able to.
What is your plan, Jessica, for confronting Pete?
I don't know yet.
I don't, I just found it.
I don't know.
I am, my blood is boiling though right now and I am, I don't know if I am going to pack my stuff and just get out of here
or I'm just going to, Jessica, Jessica, I'm going to tell you from a guy's point of view
who has been caught cheating when he's been living with girls that he's been with.
Just walk away.
Like honestly, that's the best way to do it for both of you guys because you leave,
you can find someone else who's not going to cheat on you and if you don't leave
then you're always going to have that doubt.
You're always going to be on his case.
It's not going to be a good relationship on either side.
So no matter what, now that you know this, my advice to you would be just to go there when he's
not there, get your stuff, don't even give him the satisfaction of a conversation about it.
Because all he's going to do is lie about it.
Right?
I mean, how many times have you been honest,
you pull when you had gotten caught and cheated?
I am never honest.
So Jessica, that's what I would tell you to do, okay?
Thank you.
I mean, I guess I'm glad I'm finding this out.
I'm not at all, but yeah.
Hey, it's better to know now than to have to get a divorce, right?
And let me tell you, we through one badass, un-bachelorette party in Vegas after my girlfriend broke
up with her second fiance.
And it was way more fun.
Hey, Jessica, will you stay in touch with us?
Just to let us know how you're doing and how everything wraps up?
Yeah.
All right.
You're going to be okay.
Thanks, guys.
Yeah, it's not the end of the world.
It really isn't.
I know it sucks right now, but it's not.
Hello?
Hey, I was looking for Phil.
Yeah, speaking.
Who is this?
This is Jubel from Brook and Jubel in the morning.
I'm moving 92.5.
How are you?
92.5.
Oh my god, are you serious?
Wow.
Yes, I, this is the reaction I get when I call most people.
Oh, don't worry about it.
What's up, man?
How are you doing?
I'm great.
How are you?
Good.
Do you know why I might be calling you?
You know I do it.
Have you ever heard one of the second-aid updates that we do?
Kind of, it kind of sort of, yeah.
Do you sounds like you're not too familiar?
If you don't know what a second-aid update is, it's where you go out and date with someone
and then blow them off after.
Then they email us and ask us to call you to find out why.
So I'd do somebody off?
Yep.
Any idea what that could be?
Um, geez.
I mean, I didn't kind of go on a date like last week.
This girl Rachel.
And has Rachel texted you and called you after the date to try to maybe hang out again?
There's a couple times, uh, I think she may have left me a message.
And you haven't responded to her, which technically means you blew her off.
So you, we are.
What's that?
Great.
Men's brains work.
Oh, yeah.
Is that what?
Rachel wants to know why you won't call her back.
Is there any particular reason?
Well, man, to be completely honest, man.
You know, she was just a little weird.
She was a little weird.
What?
I figured that it was embarrassment.
I figured you weren't calling her back because you were embarrassed.
But you say it's because she's weird.
Oh, yeah, yeah, it turns out, you know, like all the stuff that we talked about.
She didn't really tell me everything about herself, you know, like pertinent information.
So what do you mean by that?
What do you mean by everything about herself?
You go on dates because, you know, you want to get to know somebody a little bit better.
Maybe you see if it leaves something else.
Yeah, I was going to say hook up after it.
But, uh, friends, somebody will have different reasons for dating.
So what do you find out about it?
Like, you know, so after the date, you know, I went back and went to my friends and I was like,
you know, I went out with this awesome girl named Rachel and I actually showed them a picture of her.
And uh, a boy was like, this is the same girl that was dating a mutual friend of ours.
Oh, man.
All right, hold on.
How do you guys really know that that's the same person?
Facebook?
Yeah, I could pick a pull picture right now.
We actually found the profile with boyfriend, right?
And we were going through his pictures.
She's on the profile picture making out with home dude.
What?
Wait, so she's cheated?
Yeah, apparently the status thing, there's a relationship and it says her name.
Oh, no.
And not even just dating him.
Wait, no, wait, I'm playing.
Hey, Phil.
Yeah.
I should probably, you know, that Rachel is on the other line and heard everything that you just said.
Are you serious?
So he, yeah, I, Phil, hi.
He was just, let me explain.
Yes, that was my boyfriend, but we're definitely not dating anymore.
We've been broken up for the last two months.
I just lived with him.
It was a little bit of a complicated situation, but we're definitely not in a relationship.
Rachel, did you say you just live with him?
Yeah, it's a little complicated, you know, but yeah, I live with him, but we're not together.
We're not officially to get broke up.
It's over.
It's been over.
Well, why are you living with him?
It's just a little complicated.
I'm moving out soon.
We know I'm working it out, but for right now, we're still, you know, sharing the same space.
And how soon is soon?
Like, as soon as I possibly can.
Rachel, I've been in a similar situation where I've broken up with someone I lived with and we
had to live together for a couple of months because, you know, things just didn't work out.
Are you guys still sleeping together?
Yeah.
Well, I mean, sometimes, I get that when you admit it, that's not a problem.
At least you're on as a, and it's obvious.
It only, it's like, happened like once or twice.
And honestly, like, it's not an emotional thing at all.
It's just a physical thing.
I mean, you know, like, we do see each other every single day.
Right.
When I say that we're officially over, it we're a physical person.
I'm glad that you admit it because I give you said no, I was going to call you out because
this is the same way.
I would not have been in that situation.
You have your moments of weakness, you know.
Yeah, she says it's physical, but you have an ex boyfriend that still has a profile pick.
Yeah.
That is not physical to him.
I can guarantee it.
I mean, yeah, but I mean, I don't want to.
I don't want to why he still has that on there.
Because he still would love with you and a little obsessed.
And he's so banging.
Yeah.
I know that's another good point.
I mean, I guess, but I have, I changed my Facebook profile.
For me, it's definitely over.
And for me, I definitely want to date.
Phil, I really liked him.
I had a really good time on our date.
I would love to see him again and see where this can go.
And I thought we had a really good time.
If you're doing this to this guy, you know,
what's the say that you're not going to do this to me in a couple of months?
Yeah, I mean, you can say that.
I understand we're coming from, but it's a very particular situation.
I can tell it to you in detail later off the radio if you want, but I mean,
just give me a chance, you know.
Hey, Rachel.
Oh, God.
How about you explain to Phil all about your relationship or ex relationship on your next date?
Because I would love to offer you guys a second date.
We will pay for it.
Phil?
It's not so painful.
Would you go out with Rachel again?
I got to say no, man.
Oh, no.
You do not blame him.
In a second date full of listening about her ex boyfriend.
That sounds horrible.
Sounds like a lot of fun.
I mean, he didn't come on Phil.
I got to say no because because this is the tables were turned, you know, I can't pull something
like that off.
Yeah, right.
Oh, I got a girlfriend, but you know, I want to go out and date you.
Like no, also.
Everyone, everybody would be calling you a huge D bag at the moment.
Yeah.
Rachel, maybe you should wait to date until you actually move out.
Yeah, you're probably right.
I, this is getting really complicated and making pretty impossible for me to meet anyone.
It's often complicated to date when you're still sleeping with your old boyfriend.
Hello, Kevin.
Hey, Kevin, how are you?
This is Jubel from Brook and Jubel in the morning on Moven 92.5.
Who?
Jubel from Brook and Jubel in the morning on the radio station Moven 92.5.
Have you heard of us?
Now I have.
Awesome.
Well, start.
We also morning radio show from 6 to 10.
You should check it out, especially since you're going to be on it right now.
Yeah.
I want to talk to you about a girl that you recently went on a date with.
Okay.
Her name is Stacey.
Now, we do a segment on her show called the second date update.
When somebody goes out on a date with someone they really like and then gets blown off,
they email us to call that person and find out why Stacey is wondering why you won't
call her back.
Oh, okay.
Do you remember going on a date with a girl named F.
Law and accurate cause?
Yes.
Did you do something wrong on the date?
I mean, let's just say she's a little fast for me.
So fast for you?
Yeah.
And I'm assuming you don't mean like, you should think she could run a mile
quicker than you like.
No, no.
We had a lovely evening that was going very well.
And then things proceeded like they do when an evening is going very well.
And then it just started to to get a little too heated.
How's it work?
She said that you were watching a movie and you guys started to kiss a little bit.
Yeah.
And then in the middle of that kissing your upstairs neighbors decided to do more than
kissing very loud.
Yeah.
And there was an awkward moment.
She said she made a joke and like, oh, maybe it's a sign.
And then you didn't laugh at it and she thought maybe she upset you.
Alright, I'll be totally honest there.
Uh, I'm trying to save
myself.
Oh, you're okay.
Okay.
So you're saving yourself from Mary.
Nothing wrong with that.
There's a lot of things.
I was going to tell you all the problems.
It's wrong with the guys.
You're saving yourself from Mary, you're virgin.
Yes, yes, I'm a virgin.
So did you not get her joke?
I mean, she was just joking about it being a sign that you guys should do it.
No, she didn't really seem like it was a joke.
I mean, it was it was said, but there was a little more intention behind the joke.
And things just got pretty awkward pretty quickly.
And I realized, you know, as wonderful as she is, she's the kind of girl that might want to move
faster than I would be able to.
And she's incredibly attractive.
She's in this.
So that kind of temptation is incredibly hard to fight.
How do you get that impression, though, Kevin, that she is that kind of girl?
Well, it was heard that sort of initiated the kissing.
I'm a big fan of kissing.
So I wasn't really going to stop because I was like,
she's incredibly attractive.
And what's all you got right now?
Yeah, I was like, I was like, bracing, right?
I mean, I was definitely very tempted.
And there was definitely the kind of girl that my mom always warned me about.
Oh, guys.
Kevin, what are you?
What do you mean?
I'm old enough to make my own decision.
Yeah, you know, I do still hold onto the lessons my mom teach me.
Right. And Kevin, I'm assuming that since you met Stacey at church,
you're a pretty churchy guy.
I'm a fairly, you know, I'm a fairly churchy guy.
That is pretty religious.
A churchy is always like that.
So you just feel that she is way too loose of a woman.
Pretty cute.
I guess I think she, I mean, I'm not that too my own horn.
You're much better.
Just don't think she'd be able to control herself.
There comes a down here.
There's a person.
Hey, Eric, it's virgin.
Kevin?
Yes, sir.
I do have to let you know that Stacey is actually online.
And we heard everything you just said.
Good.
Lord.
That does not have been in vain.
Yeah, agree.
Hey, Stacey.
Then say hi to Kevin.
Oh boy.
Kevin, so that's the reason, huh?
I mean, do you have any idea what you're missing album?
No, he doesn't.
Yeah.
It's just no sex or something that I'm firmly, I firmly believe that it's something that you
want to save because it's special and it shouldn't be just paused to the side at any moment.
It should be something that people really want to do for the right reason.
I mean, if you think kissing is great.
Stacey, you're not saying that you want a date of virgin.
You're saying that you want a convertive virgin.
No, no, that is not what I'm saying.
Kevin, you're searching for another virgin.
I wouldn't necessarily say another virgin per se, but definitely someone that holds the same values
or at least be able to hold to the same values.
Kevin, to be honest, we had such a great time with our private pizza making party and pizza
bite and everything.
I cannot believe I'm going to say this, but I would actually be willing to give up
sex to go out with you again.
Kevin, you've actually made a woman not want to have sex ever again.
Kevin's crazy.
Now, I have to tell you your body was telling me something completely different.
Oh, well, and I don't know if I'm being word.
You truly restrained yourself.
She's not going to take you to the room.
Just, you know, have her way with you.
Yeah, like you have a little bit of a saying it too.
And Kevin, are you crazy?
Like, how many women are offering this for you?
I mean, I don't know many girls that would just stop having sex because they
meet a guy who's that great.
Thank you.
Like, Brooke, she's got a husband and she still has sex with dudes all the time.
You know, like she doesn't stop for him.
Yeah, yeah.
Good, Kevin.
I know you say you're going to be able to wait, but just from what you'd said,
a second ago, look at what you're giving up.
So I just questioned that.
That's all.
I think you should have a little faith.
Oh, good line.
Stay as you just want to take it.
Yeah.
I'm not going to take it.
You just want to take it.
I want that big card.
All right.
Well, that being said, would love to offer you guys the second date?
We will pay for it.
If I say, yeah, you think we'd be able to control ourselves.
I do.
I promise.
All right, let's do it.
Yeah, I'm going to do it.
You're going to go out with Stacey again.
Let's do it.
Well, you're going to go out with her again.
You're not going to do it.
Yeah.
But you will go out on another date.
Wrong choice.
Sorry.
All right.
It's Stacey.
Well, congratulations.
You got your date.